Blue Lake Cab podcast special guests
represent San Bernardino yes sir he
calls himself the greatest rapper to
ever come out of the IE that's correct
of all time that is correct yes
I respect that I have to well you gotta
prove it now yeah I do any music out
absolutely tons of Music where can
people go to find you
find me at cam Archer everywhere
c-a-m-a-r-c-h-e-r my last project of
Guapo three dropped in a couple months
ago a couple months ago that's what's
new yeah it's newer yeah but you can
find I got tons of music albums on
albums of music all streaming platforms
music I'm embarrassed about it's all
over the Internet it's all there yeah
whatever you want to get but whatever
you want to get yo the best rapper to
ever come out of the IE self-proclaimed
yeah we're gonna find out shout out to
all the legends from my city but y'all
know
hit the beat
[Music]
wow yeah nice and crispy yeah all right
look [ __ ] it
yeah Dino City till I'm lifeless they
say come stay in LA but I'd rather rep
with pride outside that Baker's where my
ride is come and find it collecting my
titles making that Timeless [ __ ] to
prophecy [ __ ] know that I don't like
surprises got it out for me you should
know ain't no [ __ ] in my Iris as a kid
I was applaud at any time I wanna fight
if I start the [ __ ] grew up in
apartments now my party set apart with
all this dope I'm on my Carter [ __ ]
carbon rounds in every clip shoot it
like I'm stripping twister yakovich a
little Steph only cause she shimmy when
I empty and employ a ref if you want to
win that's why they envy him go don't
always glitter every Lyricist ain't
Eminem I've been feeling insulted but
now ain't soaking with young home alone
while Brody traffic thought of coking
the reason if I really start boring and
need the code in a star right here in
the moment I'm raining just like Dakota
don't press me to make a quota my homies
define loyal they'll probably pop at the
POTUS than flee in the old Tacoma was
worried about my mental but [ __ ] it I'm
good to shoulder the hopes of my area
code plus the chip I've been growing
since like 2010 was spitting in but
wasn't getting spins the only Joe I had
to spend is with the Bro with Lynn I'm
about to just like CP3 as soon as the
money in my lady knows she with a gold I
call her Lil Kim she five one and I'm
51.50 I hit your Bae shut it down like
the Carter 360. I'm talking Vince in
2000 no more Nino stay with me plus the
50s and the raps that's elevating you
digging wait wait so we did Dak Prescott
we did some Carter flips you know I'm
good with those we gonna mix in some
wrestling some anime we're gonna get
back to the bathroom all right look
I'll be jumping out the gym in this
[ __ ] no Athletics I'm special cause I
excel with all the hate that they give
it's him they tried to Pepper my name I
Crown in my scepter but the shepherd's
still bawling like watching the butter
Rim it's Guapo ghost face never leave no
Trace they hate solely cause they
sucking ain't got no taste can't dress
ain't flying a [ __ ] count low my next
chain Gonna Shine Like A Ric Flair robe
[ __ ] unoriginal so you knew how they
knew [ __ ] goes can't switch bros man
that [ __ ] ain't goes I'm time biting my
likeness is quite frightening to
Outsiders that want to try attacking a
Titan look homie that's a Fool's errand
this white God I'm seeing bosses like we
keep Cameron's say I'm trash but you
keep caring you see the run that my crew
on my [ __ ] turn [ __ ] like they rewind
and Mulan can't hold the grudge jockles
you on over any classic a new song to
drive out of DuPont in other words I'm
24 on the track but the potential like
Kobe with the eight on his back if they
repping oh he just know they ain't after
that if I let it clap a QB I just read
and react and speak saying he the best
in the world some agree but I'm best in
the IE so what does that make me
[ __ ] good we can go to the next
one I'm just saying man if speaks thinks
he's like the best in IE and I'm from
the ie
it's just math you know I mean like yeah
that's what we do in my city we rap
that's what we do
OE and his [ __ ] I.E in this [ __ ]
rest in peace to Prodigy rest in peace
of Magnolia let's get it popping this
[ __ ] yeah
let me keep it cheap I've been in
seclusion looping lunacy my newest
speech Just proven no confusion dog it's
you and me using my illusion Fusion
dancing on a Widow's Peak training speed
Vegeta delete I'm worrying for the week
way too much collusion between these
demons and Reapers I took what they
ain't wanna relinquish just find us
Keepers my calendar Mayan Master the
science to find The Seekers while you in
the now running with puppets they cousin
see they're disgusting look what you
stuck with flow is like throw up sick my
brother throwing upsets before the
bullet struck hit retaliation man dated
cameras fan appreciated so I'm at a
distance so with charges I'm not plugged
in from a lion's den where you die if
you bring the Cubs in respect only comes
from your character and his contents
play me for a rook man that's Pawn [ __ ]
I'm accomplished exposing hella clowns
lately I've been on that spawn [ __ ] Dino
sponsored I'm the deadliest on the scene
everybody's hop got to the champion hit
the screen say what I mean look in the
mirror I'm who you see when calling
Candyman you think I came from Cabrini
Green they ain't efficient they finicky
facility for plenty cream click more
familiar with of misdemeanors than
Timothy I could tell this wasn't the
future you've been envisioning these
[ __ ] die for power they reenacting the
Kennedys the same Cam that had a crush
on Kimberly racking up accolades like my
after school assemblies tackled you
can't evade a Vegas Raider in a cup of
three only Lupe on his best day could
humble me I.E rappers don't run [ __ ]
they run from me wait wait let me get
back let me get back in the mode you
know I'm saying recipes to Prodigy rest
in peace Mac Miller recipes Jason David
Frank rest in peace Kevin Conroy we got
to get the love out the way before we
get back to hitting these [ __ ] over
the head you feel me yeah
yeah look look yeah
I'd sell them
I can feel the hate ramping as I trample
through Mighty with my morph on my final
form tyrannical had a childhood in the
wild Hood coursing through my veins is
my mama's pain gotta be an oracle can't
remember orders of operation but all the
work historical never seen it come and
take a listen let me portal you like
Johnny Cage when he finally fell
fighting scorpion let the corpses
welcome [ __ ] to hell how glorious fine
chilling laborious rather gather floral
patterns from my Ops let them sort them
I had to drop their eyelashes for
attempting to floor my Limitless rise
got a price that none of them can afford
meet the night good luck good looking we
only putting numbers up that's crooked
Cali cooking don't mistake this [ __ ] for
Brooklyn I'm him that one love settled
on top of the brim they copy and paste
but wasted cause they lacking the stems
you jacking who you must have me mixed
with them for my destiny risk lights and
limb that mean Family Tree I'll die for
I see my seeds condensed expand fences
the garden immense we in the trenches
ready for every given expense don't be
senseless or I'll send men to locate
what your every cent is and knock your
penny tray off your track record harder
than the playoffs I'm KD quick Jay off
complacency easy to spot look how they
fumble when they entrusted with the rock
see them crumble while I stack chips up
for the stock such an easy call I
survived every series learned to see him
fall [ __ ] that share in this caring [ __ ]
man we need it all
we in this [ __ ] I.E in this [ __ ] cam
Archer and his [ __ ] you understand what
I'm saying I'm the best in the world if
you ask me I don't know what else you
asking but if you asking me
that's what the [ __ ] I do
hey what up I know you just watched the
crazy freestyle and guess what we got
another one coming out next week and
another one coming out the week after
and it's all presented by our family at
LRG that's right LRG uh first of all
shout out to them because they just
dropped this fire collab with Ewing
Athletics they got the sneakers they got
the sweatsuit the T-shirt all that plus
I want to give a big shout out to them
because it is Christmas time and my
promo code at lrg's website is a serious
one you saved 30 off 30 off if you go to
l-r-g.com and use the promo code bootleg
you'll save 30 off whatever the [ __ ] you
want on lrg's website so it's Christmas
time maybe you need some new gear maybe
you need a new jacket maybe you need a
new [ __ ] sweatsuit whatever it is
l-r-g.com we appreciate them for holding
us down use that promo code bootleg safe
30 off and we'll see you next week with
another freestyle presented by LRG